in this video I'm going to explain how
to use the traffic pattern at almost any
us
[Music]
Airfield welcome to Free pilot training
I'm Josh and today we're going to be
talking about how to use airport traffic
patterns knowing how to use the traffic
pattern is one of the most important
things you need to know how to do as a
pilot pilots who don't know how to use
the traffic pattern make it way more
dangerous for everyone else at the very
least these people make it super
annoying when you're trying to do
pattern work so sit back and relax and
let's talk about airport traffic
patterns airport traffic patterns or
circuits as some people call them are
invisible routs that are flown around a
Runway to allow air traffic to flow
smoothly and efficiently in and out of
an Airfield now you're not going to be
expected to be an expert on all traffic
patterns at every airport but if you
have a basic understanding of what
you're expected to do in a normal
rectangular pattern this is going to
help the traffic flow so much smoother
and if you fly the pattern like you're
opposed to other Pilots are going to
know where to look for you and this can
keep them from crashing into you in fact
according to the NTSB most midair
collisions are caused by pilots failing
to see and avoid each other we'll talk
more about this in a minute but I want
you to see that there are specific spots
in the pattern that are more dangerous
than others so it's very important that
we use the pattern the way it's designed
to be used so now let's talk about how
to do that VFR traffic patterns are
shaped like a rectangle and ideally we
want to to fly the pattern so that we
land our airplane into the wind because
of that many of the legs that you fly in
the rectangular pattern are named with
this in mind for example when you fly
downwind with the wind you're on the
downwind leg then when you fly on this
leg where you're flying in a crosswind
you're actually flying the crosswind leg
mind blown these names actually make
sense don't they in fact there's
actually another leg that's not labeled
here that we could be flying into the
wind above the runway and that's called
the upwind leg we'll talk more about
that in a minute but most of the time
when you're flying in the pattern you're
trying to take off land and make touch
and goes so we have the short little leg
here in front of our landing spot that
we call final and this leg over here
past our takeoff spot is what we call
the departure leg then last but not
least we have the base leg Yeah I have
no clue why it's called that you're just
going to have to remember that one keep
in mind if you have to land with a
Tailwind for some reason these names
don't change they're based on the runway
you're using not the direction of the
wind so don't let that confuse you
here's where things can get a little
confusing standard traffic patterns are
made by making leftand turns around the
runway for example if I took off from
Runway 36 here in a standard traffic
pattern I would turn left over to
crosswind and then left again over to
downwind and so on in fact when we fly
the standard left-and pattern these legs
are named according to the pattern
direction for example this is left
crosswind and this is left downwind
and this is left base pop quiz for you
what do you think this leg is nope this
is not left final I don't know how many
times I've heard students say this on
the radio but left final isn't a thing
final upwind and departure don't get
special names they're just final upwind
and departure don't be that guy that
says left final we're all going to laugh
at you if you do this but anyway not all
runways are left-hand patterns some of
them are right-hand patterns like this
one and in this case we'd make right
turns over to right crosswind right
downwind and right base and right got
you it's just final not right final so
the pattern Direction determines the
name of these legs it has nothing to do
with the side of the runway you're on
don't let that confuse you okay so
left-hand patterns are the standard
traffic pattern but how do we know if we
have a left-hand pattern or a right-and
pattern if your Runway has a leftand
pattern there won't actually be anything
that tells you that because the standard
traffic pattern is leftand turns but
there are a couple ways that you can
determine if your Runway has a right-and
pattern in my opinion the easiest way to
find the pattern direction is to look at
the VFR sectional let's take a look at
Bartlesville municipal airport on the
VFR sectional notice this rp17 down here
at the bottom of the airport information
block this lets us know that Runway 17
is a right pattern so we need to make a
rectangle with right turns when we land
on this Runway but which direction
should we turn when we land on Runway 35
there's nothing that tells us what to do
that's right because the left-and
patterns are standard and you can assume
that the pattern is leftand turns if
they don't tell you now there is one
other place you can check out if you
want to be 100% sure about the pattern
direction another great place to look is
the chart supplement in the runway
information line take a look at the
runway information for Runway 17 here at
the end of the line it says right
traffic so we know that this Runway has
a right pattern but once again Runway 35
doesn't have that Noe so we can assume
that 35 is a standard left hand pattern
keep in mind you could be asked to use a
left or right hand pattern at a towered
airport in that case you want to use the
pattern that they tell you to use in
those situations Tower is trying to
sequence everyone to the runway to build
spacing and keep everyone safe it's very
important to pay attention and do what
they tell you so you don't run into
someone else for example your Runway
might be a standard left-hand pattern
but Tower might say this Skyhawk 3148
x-ray make right downwind 18 right
downwind 18 Skyhawk 3148 x-ray in this
case we would want to enter a right
downwind which would mean that we're
making a right turn to right base and a
right turn to final now there's actually
one more way that you can determine
which way the traffic pattern goes and
that's by something called a segmented
Circle I'm going to be honest I never
look at these things but a lot of people
do and this is something that you could
be asked about on your written exam or
even the check ride at many airports
there's often a segmented circle around
the wind sock that tells you if your
Runway has a left or right-and pattern
and these are really simple to use take
a look at these little L's around the
circle the big part of the L represents
the runway and the little part
represents the base leg so if our wind
is out of the Northwest like our wind
sock is showing then that means we want
to land on this tiny little North Runway
here then this little part represents
the base leg so that means we're going
to be making a left turn onto final from
base in other words this North Runway
here is a left-hand pattern if we were
Landing to this South it looks like that
Runway would be a right hand pattern
because we'd be making a right turn to
Final in that case that's interesting
there must be something on the other
side of this airport that they don't
want us flying
over hey Goose let's go buzz whatever
that
is uh are you sure that's a good idea
M oh boy probably not a great idea but
you know what is a great idea snatching
up yourself a pair of these core
Aviation headsets and these are a great
little starter headset for a super low
cost and if you want an even lower cost
you can use coupon code free pilot
training talk about a great starter
headset and there's really no risk
because if you decide you don't like
them you could just give them to your
passengers later on down the road and
buy yourself a super expensive one if
you're into that but I think you're
going to find the quality is UN nashed
and I think you guys are going to like
these so be sure to check these out
let's get on with the training how big
should we make a rectangular pattern
according to the airplane flying
handbook the downwind leg should be
flown somewhere around 1/2 to 1 mile
from the Runway and then you should turn
base when you're at a point
approximately 45° from the runway and
this means that you should also be 1/2
Mile to 1 mile from final and then 1/2
to 1 mile from the runway when you turn
final this is one of my biggest pet pees
when it comes to Flying the pattern
there are so many Pilots out there who
make giant traffic patterns like they're
flying a B-52 bomber and I wouldn't care
but if you do this it's really going to
mess up the spacing in the pattern
because an aircraft on a 3 Mile downwind
has to fly a further distance than
someone who's making their traffic
pattern right next to the runway like
they're supposed to for example if
someone's on downwind 3 miles in front
of me but they're 2 miles away from the
runway when they turn base they'll be
one mile from where they should be and
if I'm 3 mil behind this clown and we're
flying the same speed we could very
easily run into each other if I'm not
paying attention when I turn base
[Music]
here not only that but I shouldn't have
to be looking around trying to find this
guy if he's where he should be he's
going to be a lot easier to spot so we
don't run into each other and die and
dying really isn't on my bucket list
well I guess it kind of is isn't it that
being said I'm not going to be too mad
at you if you extend your downwind a
little bit in the beginning of your
training I like to have my newer
students drive out a little farther so
they can have a nice long final which
makes it a lot easier to get stabilized
during the approach it's a lot easier to
learn how to land the airplane when you
start by making a stable approach
so we want to fly the traffic pattern
correctly so all the traffic flows
smoothly and other Pilots know where to
look for us one the way we can do that
is by flying the correct altitude
according to the aim if you're flying an
airplane with a propeller it's highly
recommended that you fly a pattern at
1,000 ft above the surface large
aircraft or turbine powerered aircraft
should fly their patterns at 1,500 ft
AGL now I know it might be a while
before you fly one of these airplanes
with a higher traffic pattern but I
still think it's something you should
know about because if you're flying
above the airport at 1,500 ft AGL that
doesn't always mean that you're flying
at a safe altitude it's kind of funny
when I was flying the herk I actually
flew normal patterns at 1,000 fet AGL
but the aim and other FAA Publications
are clear that these altitudes are only
a recommendation but I think that most
Pilots would agree that it's a good idea
to the correct altitude so it's easier
for other people to see you it can also
keep you from running into obstacles and
terrain above the runway in fact traffic
patterns aren't always at 1,000 ft for
propeller driven aircraft at some
airports the FAA will actually publish a
specific altitude if they think it's
safer to do so for example let's take a
look at Batesville Regional Airport over
in central Arkansas now the quickest way
to determine pattern altitude is to look
at the field elevation here in the
airport information block and at 1,000
ft in this example our field elevation
is 465 ft so if I add 1,000 ft to that
we could determine that our pattern
altitude should be at
1,465 FT MSL remember traffic pattern
altitudes are a recommendation because
of that most Pilots typically round this
number up to the nearest 100 ft so
normally we'd fly this pattern at 1,500
ft MSL but there's one more thing we
need to check anytime you fly into a new
airport one of the most important things
to check is the chart supplement this
document gives you way more information
about the Airfield than the airport
information block on the VFR sectional
and here in the first block of the
supplement for Batesville is where we
can confirm the exact altitude for the
airport as you may have guessed this TPA
stands for traffic pattern altitude and
here at Batesville the pattern altitude
is actually 1,250 ft MSL which is 785 ft
AGL if the airport has a standard
pattern altitude of 1,000 ft AGL this
note won't be up here in this block
take a look at the supplemental data for
Bald Knob municipal airport what a great
name anyway this airport doesn't mention
anything about the traffic pattern
altitude so in this case it's safe to
assume that the pattern is 1,000 ft
above the surface now I'm not entirely
sure why the pattern altitude over at
Batesville is lower than the standard
pattern but I'm sure they have a reason
for doing this maybe they wanted more
spacing below this MOA or maybe they
knew that c130s like to follow this
River here and the lower pattern
altitude keeps Pilots closer to the
Airfield either way if you fly into
Batesville the best altitude to fly in
the pattern is 1,250 ft MSL now there's
one other thing you should know about
when it comes to pattern altitude this
is something I wish more instructors
would teach because I've actually had
people cut in front of me onto crosswind
when I'm climbing out on the departure
leg when should we be turning onto the
crosswind leg well according to the
airplane flying handbook we should be
turning crosswind beyond the departure
into the runway and when we're within
300 ft of the pattern altitude so if my
pattern altitude is 1,600 ft MSL I
should not be turning crosswind until
I'm at least 1300 ft MSL keep in mind
there are some airports where this might
not be possible take a look at this
airport beneath the class Charlie shelf
for Adams Field this is North L Rock
municipal airport and let's say that
we're climbing out on the departure leg
for Runway 5 here the departure into
this Runway is just over a mile from the
class Delta airspace over at Little Rock
Air Force Base now there are some
airplanes that might be able to climb
fast enough to make this work but most
of the time you're going to have to turn
early if you don't want to bust the
class Delta there because remember we
have to have two-way radio conss with
the tower before we can go into that
airspace and a lot of you guys aren't
going to be able to handle that radio
call while still making CA calls at the
same time at airports like this you kind
of just have to use your best judgment
when it comes to Flying a good pattern
if no one's in front of you turn as late
as you can without busting the airspace
but if another aircraft's in front of
you just follow their ground track as
long as they're not busting the airspace
in fact this is a pretty good rule in
general even if this guy's an idiot and
he's making his pattern too big it's
still a good idea to match his ground
track that way we don't have an incident
like I mentioned earlier where we
somehow get too close because I'm closer
to the runway and I have a shorter
distance to travel maybe you're that guy
but it's not on purpose it could be that
the wind's just pushing you around and
causing your pattern to be too big or
too small the wind is an important
consideration when it comes to Flying a
good rectangular pattern in a perfect
world The Wind should be directly
aligned with a Runway and it wouldn't
even be a problem but one of the first
things you're going to learn about
flying is that the weather never
cooperates completely so we have to
account for Crosswinds if we want to fly
a good pattern and the way we do that is
by crabbing our aircraft into the wind
now I'm not going to sit here and give
you some big spill about crabbing into
the wind all you need to really do is
look outside and see where your airplane
is going remember we want to fly our
airplane parallel with the Runway about
1/2 to 1 mile away so if we're getting
pushed over just crab a little more but
be careful not to angle yourself too
much this can keep you from flying a
straight line as well now for some
reason most CFI is in the discussion
right there but there's actually one
other thing you want to think about when
it comes to Crosswinds and if you learn
this early in your training it might
actually help you make better crosswind
Landings anytime there's a crosswind
that win could potentially cause you to
overshoot or unders shoot final and if
you're trying to make good good Landings
you know how important it is to be
stable on Final so if we want to set
ourselves up for a nice straight final
we need to be thinking about what the
winds are doing for example if I'm
turning from left base onto final and I
have a right to left crosswind we have
what we call an undershooting wind this
undershooting wind is going to cause me
to undershoot final so we fix that by
driving out another potato or two before
we turn on to final and that's going to
put me in a much better position for a
stable approach keep in mind we could
also have a left to right cross wind and
this is what we call an overshooting
wind if we turn in the same place we
normally do this wind is going to cause
us to overshoot final so in this case we
want to turn early and being stable
isn't the only reason why you want to
think about this it's not unusual for an
airport to have parallel runways like
you see here what would happen if you
didn't account for an overshooting wind
and somebody else was on Final for this
other Runway over here yeah you could
potentially transgress into their area
over there and that could cause a
serious accident in fact look where the
NTSB says that most accidents occur on
Final and short final so we really need
to pay attention to those winds and fly
the airplane over a nice rectangular
ground track around the runway and
speaking of accidents let's talk about
entering and exiting the pattern because
if you don't know how to enter and exit
the pattern properly you could be a
danger to everyone else in the pattern
if you're flying at a towered airport
most of the time ATC is going to tell
you how to enter the pattern Scout 314
x-ray make left base for eight left base
18 314 x-ray at this point I would just
fly directly over to left base and enter
the pattern there but at a non-towered
airport there's actually a specific spot
where you should be entering
unfortunately there are a ton of Pilots
out there who enter the pattern wherever
they want and you'll also see guys
making straight ends at every Airfield
they fly into but that's not what they
should be doing the safest thing to do
is to enter the pattern at a 45° angle
in the middle of the field on downwind
now I can sense that somebody watching
this video is getting red hot because
the faa's advisory circular on
non-towered Airport flight operations
actually says this about entering the
traffic pattern the FAA does not
regulate traffic pattern entry only
traffic pattern flow so there's nothing
that legally says that you have to enter
here on downwind but I want you to
notice something else that this document
also says the FAA does not recommend
that the pilot execute a straight in
approach for landing when there are
other aircraft in the traffic pattern
the straight end approach may cause a
conflict with aircraft in the traffic
pattern and on base to final and
increase the risk of a midair Collision
look back at a chart from the NTSB
according to this chart 50% of all
midair collisions occur on Final and
short final so when you make a straight
end you're taking a huge risk if there
are other aircraft already in the
pattern I think a lot of Pilots get
confused because of the RightWay rules
in Far
9113 notice what it says here in section
g aircraft while on Final Approach to
land or while Landing had the right of
way over other aircraft in flight or
operating on the surface this does not
mean you have the right away if you're
making a straight end this is talking
about somebody that's already
established on the Final Approach
segment of the actual traffic pattern
you can't just cut people off that are
on Bas about to turn final they're
already in the pattern in fact the FAA
actually clarifies 9113 in that same
advisory circular we just mentioned
let's see what they say about making a
straightend approach the FAA discourages
VFR straightend approaches to Landings
due to increased risk of a midair
Collision however if a pilot chooses to
execute a straightend approach for a
landing without entering the airport
traffic pattern the pilot should self
announce their position blah blah blah
and then look at this Pilots choosing to
execute a straight-in approach do not
have a particular priority over other
aircraft in the traffic pattern and must
comply with the provisions in 9113
so whoever cut me off the other day
while I was on Bas leg I would really
appreciate it if you brush up on how to
use the pattern you could have easily
killed both of us and at what cost yeah
you landed maybe 5 minutes sooner but
I'm telling you it's not worth it but if
streading approaches are so dangerous
why doesn't the FAA just make him IL
legal well one reason for this is
because it's actually safer to enter a
straight in at some airports take a look
at this Airport in North Little Rock
Arkansas let's say I wanted to land on
Runway 5 here what would I have to do to
enter the pattern for Runway 5 over on
Midfield downland well one thing is I'd
have to fly over Camp Robinson here
that's not really a big deal if I have
two-way with Little Rock approach
because I could just go into the class
Charlie above that but if I don't have
two-way radio coms I personally don't
want to be flying that close to the
bottom of the Class C shelf here the
other thing is these restricted areas
here even if I squeeze in between these
airfields I'd have to make a super tight
turn so I don't go into this restricted
area oh and the patterns for 18 and 36
are both on this side of the runway so
I'd have to make sure that no one was in
those patterns either to me this is a
classic example of why the FAA allows
straight ends but they're highly
discouraged another reason for this is
that instrument approaches are typically
straight ends as well yes instrument
approaches are typically made during bad
weather when VFR Pilots shouldn't be
flying but IFR Pilots also need to train
and practice these when the weather's
nice as well so if you hear someone on
the radio saying that they're on the r
app for Runway 5 here you can typically
assume that they're making a straight in
and you should do your best to
accommodate them North wi Rock traffic
Cherokee 7348 Juliet 5 miles out on an
ar05 Full Stop North Little Rock 48
Juliet this is Skyhawk 3148 x-ray
turning crosswind for 05 I've got you in
sight and I'll follow behind you notice
how we're working together to prevent a
collision let's make airports safe again
buy one of my new t-shirts if you agree
but I'm not running for president feel
free to write my name in on the ballot
this year if you want though now you
know the preferred method for entering
the pattern but what if I'm on the wrong
side of the airport and I want to still
enter on downwind if you're on the wrong
side of the Airfield there's actually
two methods that the FAA recommends to
get yourself into the pattern first we
have the preferred method to get into
the pattern using the preferred method
we want to fly over the Airfield at 500
ft above the pattern altitude so if the
traffic pattern IS300 ft MSL we'd want
to fly 500 ft above that now how how
much do you want to bet that someone
watching this is sweating bullets
because they didn't pay attention during
math class when they were a kid if you
want to be a pilot you've got to know
the three Rs and for those of you who
don't know what I'm talking about I'm
talking about reading writing and
arithmetic but I
digress anyway if we fly 500 ft above
the pattern altitude of 1300 ft MSL that
means we need to cross the Airfield at
1,800 ft MSL and after we cross the
field we want to drive out about 2 mi
past downwind and then teardrop back to
enter downwind at a 45 degree angle Pop
Quiz how far out from the runway should
we be making this turn if you're turning
2 mil past downwind remember downwind
should be somewhere between 1/2 and 1
mile from the runway so you should start
turning somewhere between 2 and 1/2 to 3
miles from the runway then before we
enter the pattern we need to descend to
pattern altitude and keep an eye out for
other aircraft as we enter this 45°
angle ideally you should be at pattern
altitude before you enter downwind now
there's actually one disadvantage to
this method what do you think that might
be who might be at 1,500 ft AGL at an
airport yeah larger turban powerered
aircraft will often fly their patterns
at 1,500 ft AGL in fact many military
aircraft regularly fly something called
an overhead approach where they enter
the pattern on upwind at 1,500 ft AGL
and then they break over to downwind if
you ever hear a military aircraft in
your pattern and you hear the word
initial that means they're lined up with
a Runway about 2 to 5 miles out and
they're setting up to do this so if
there's a larger aircraft in the pattern
or if you hear a military aircraft call
Initial you'll want to cross the field
at 2,000 ft AGL in that case so that's
the preferred method now let's look at
something called the alternate method
and I like to use this one when there's
no one else in the pattern or when I
know for sure where all the other
aircraft are for the alternate method
cross the field at pattern altitude and
then enter directly onto wind and then
just fly a normal pattern from there
keep in mind if someone else is already
on downwind you should be yielding to
them ideally if someone else is in the
pattern you should be using the
preferred entry method though now you
know how to get into the pattern but
what's the proper way to leave the
pattern leaving the pattern is pretty
straightforward literally
straightforward because that's the way
the FAA wants you to leave the pattern
is by driving straight out from the
runway after the departure leg and then
you'll climb up to your cruising
altitude from there another opt option
is to turn up to 45° towards the
downwind leg after you clear the pattern
and if you need to cross over the field
climb up and give yourself plenty of
altitude before doing that ideally you
need to cross the field at least 500 ft
above the pattern altitude keep in mind
you're not always going to be able to
depart the pattern like this at every
Airfield let's look back at Runway 5
here at North Little Rock what do you
think is departing Straight Ahead a good
idea if we wanted to part to the West no
probably not I would need to have
two-way with Little Rock Air Force Base
to go into the class Delta here and then
I'd have to have 2A with Little Rock
approach to cross back over the field on
my way out and I'd still need to be
making CA calls with North Little Rock
in this situation the best thing to do
is just to make a left downwind and
depart to the West on the downwind leg
North Little Rock traffic skyw 3148
x-ray left down one05 departing to the
west north L Rock here's where you have
to use your common sense if you want to
be a pilot yes we have the ways that we
need to enter and exit the pattern but
not all air ports are going to lend
themselves to the preferred entry and
exit methods that's why you should
always take a close look at the airport
and the airspace surrounding the airport
before you fly in there my rule is that
I fly the preferred entry and exit
methods as much as possible but if the
airspace or the terrain doesn't allow
for that my next choice is to enter or
exit the pattern using the actual legs
of the pattern there have been times
when I've had to enter the traffic
pattern on Cross wind that's not ideal
but in this situation we'd want to make
really good radio calls in fact I don't
usually make crosswind Radio Calls
because it's not required and it clogs
up the radio but in this situation I
definitely make a radio call just to be
safe Palmer traffic Skyhawk 3148 x-ray
entering the pattern on left crosswind
16 Palmer now if you do much flying at
towered airports you'll notice that they
often direct you to enter or exit the
pattern on a specific leg as well
Skyhawk 314 at x-ray clear for takeoff
one left make left downwind one left and
depart South clear for takeoff one left
left downwind one left depart South SK
314 xray okay we've learned some really
important information on how to use a
traffic pattern but there's a couple
more things I want you to know about
what should we do if we're flying into a
towered airport and we hear this Skyhawk
31 forward x-ray makes left base one
left left base one left skyw 3148 x-ray
so in this case we were directed to
enter on a left base and because of that
now we don't want to enter into Midfield
downwind we want to fly straight over
and enter at the base leg and as we
enter base we hear this Skyhawk 314 xray
clear to land one left clear to land one
left Skyhawk 314 x-ray now what should
we do if we're about to land and someone
or something is on the runway that's
right we should go around and the same
goes for a non-towered airport if
there's another aircraft or something
else on the runway like a Bus full of
nuns we need to go around now at a
towered airport I'm going to let them
know that I'm going around because if
they cleared me to land
they're expecting me to land Tower skyw
31 for xray going around one left Rog
your forhead X-ray make left close for
one left left close one left for x-ray
but what else should we do if we're
going around because there's someone
else on the runway some of you guys
already know the answer to this but if
you don't this is something that's
really important if you go around at
both towered and non-towered
airports if someone else is on the
runway you need to offset or side step
so you can see them what what happens if
we fly directly over another aircraft
yes we have a huge blind spot directly
beneath us many airplanes also have a
huge blind spot above them too so if we
don't offset our aircraft we can get
ourselves into a dangerous situation
really fast now at this point we're
actually flying on that upwind leg we
talked about earlier and if you're at a
non-towered airport this might be a
really good time to let that guy on the
runway know where you are Palmer traffic
Sky 3148 x-ray upwind 34 I'm off sitting
to the left of you here Palmer Roger we
had some engine troubles on takeoff we
should be clear the next time you come
around now there's one other thing that
you should know how to use when it comes
to the traffic pattern and that's how to
use vasis and papies I typically don't
use vasis or papies at non-towered
airports except at night but check out
this requirement from Far
91229 which outlines the requirements
for operating in class D airspace each
pilot operating an airplane approaching
to land on a Runway serve by a visual
approach slope indicator must maintain
an altitude at or above the Glide path
until a lower altitude is necessary for
a safe landing so this is basically
saying that if you're flying in a Class
D airspace you really need to be using
the vasis or the papies if they have
them so let's talk about how to use
those really quick in a nutshell visual
approach slope indicators give you a way
to follow a specific Glide path down to
a Runway and typically they bring you in
at about a 3° angle to the Runway some
are less and some are more but most
Pilots find that a 3° Glide path is just
right and as you probably already know
flying a stable Glide path is one of the
keys to making a smooth Landing that's
why a lot of instructors teach their
students to follow these visual Glide
slope indicators from the first day of
their training but one thing you should
remember is that these light systems are
mainly designed to provide obstruction
clearance in other words if you follow
their guidance you shouldn't run into
any obstacles or terrain that's why I
like using these at night but because of
that these lights can also bring you in
at a steeper angle which could throw you
off and they also bring your aim Point
further down the runway which means that
you'll touch down further as well in
fact papies typically give you an aim
Point 1,000 ft down the runway so you
can expect a touchdown somewhere between
12 and 1300 ft so if you're landing on a
shorter Runway you might not have enough
space to make a touch and go and I
personally believe this is why nighttime
currencies must be full full stop
Landings that's just my opinion but it
makes sense to me anyway let's take a
closer look at a few of these systems
first we have the visual approach slope
indicator or vassi this is the most
common Glide path system out there and
you'll typically see these at smaller
airports that don't have Precision
instrument approaches vasis give you
obstruction clearance within 10° of the
extended Center Line this means that if
you follow them over here on the base
leg you could still potentially run into
something it's okay to use them over
here but you also need to remember that
they don't give you any kind of
protection from obstructions over here
either now there are two different kind
of vases you should know about the two
bar and the three bar systems in both of
these systems the lights inside of them
are positioned so that if you're above
the light beam you'll see a white light
and if you're below the light beam
you'll see a red light two bar vasis are
very simple to use when you see two rows
of red lights that means you're low on
glide path you can remember this by
remembering red over red you're dead red
over white on the other hand means
you're all right if you see red over
white like this that means you're right
on glide path then if you see white over
white you're out of sight and that
simply means that you're too high reduce
that power or lower flaps to get
yourself down to where you need to be
three bar vasis work the same way you
just have to pick which set of vases you
want to use the lower two bars are
typically set on a 3° Glide slope just
like many of the two bars systems so
most Pilots ignore this upper bar
because if you use the two upper sets
and ignore the bottom then you're going
to come in on a slightly steeper path
typically these bring you in about a
quar degree steeper than the lower set
keep in mind three bar vasis were really
designed for larger aircraft where their
cockpit sits up a lot higher so if you
use these you're probably going to float
a little bit more than you're used to
which means you'll also need more Runway
another type of visual Glide slope
indicator is the Precision approach p
path indicator or papy these are very
similar to the vasis except they're
placed in a single row instead of on top
of each other just like the vasis you
can still use red and red you're dead
for a low Glide path red and white
you're still all right and white and
white you're out of sight but the great
thing about these is that they're also a
lot more precise because we can get
indications when we're slightly low and
slightly high and these are pretty
self-explanatory now there are a couple
more of these that supposedly exist but
I have personally never seen them one is
called the tricolor visual approach
slope indicator and the other is the
pulsating visual approach indicator this
tricolor system is pretty
self-explanatory green is good just be
cautious though because Amber can mean
both high or slightly low so just pay
attention if you ever need one of these
then the pulsating vassy on the other
hand is a little bit better a pulsating
white light tells you that you're high
and a solid white light lets you know
that once again you're all right red
you're dead and pulsating red you're so
dead that they're sending the ambulance
your
way and those are the Gory details on
how to use airport traffic patterns now
I accidentally lied to you guys a couple
of lessons ago I told you that this
would be the last video in this Ground
Force but there's actually one more
thing that we really need to talk about
and that's how to tax see in Strong
Winds Don't Worry that's going to be a
really short video and when I'm done
with that I'll throw it right here see
all right ufr stradi pilots in the words
of my generation
eat this